things like Plastics that have bpas may
be a concern drinking water may be a
concern but the most serious or enriched
source of bpas are things like printed
receipts I was out for dinner the other
night and the server came over and I
reached for the receipt and as I was
going for it like this one of the girls
who had never met before hit my hand
away like are you really going to touch
that and it's the first time I've ever
heard about this this is legit yeah
printed receipts are a rich source of
bpas and topically that could come
through this yeah it could go
transdermally I mean now you'd probably
have to handle a lot of receipts it's
gonna vary some people are operating
with a testosterone level and sperm
count that's already back on its heels
so to speak some people have abundant
testosterone and sperm this is serious
nih-funded researcher saying phthalates
before birth can dramatically alter the
trajectory of the male stability and
make sperm and testosterone so it's
really going to depend on the individual
I don't think people should get paranoid
or delusional about any of this just
don't start sleeping in a bed of receipt